passion dedication and barely enough
money to buy a used sofa on Craigslist
these are the things fan films are made
of let's recognize the hard work and
talent that went into some of the best
ones Batman versus the Terminator when
all hope is lost and humanity's demise
is certain here comes the one man crazy
enough to fight murder robots whilst
dressed as a bat you pickin this up John
the result is Batman vs. Terminator in
this animated short not only defense get
an older tough-as-nails Batman inspired
by the works of Frank Miller they also
get Batman mowing down t800 Robo
skeletons in his bat tank in the
post-apocalyptic machine controlled
earth from The Terminator movies death
scene spring-trap in the five nights at
Freddy's games players control a newly
hired security guard at the Chucky
Cheese like restaurant it's a quiet
night and everything's going normally
until the creepy animatronic animal
characters come to life this fan film
adaptation of the game isn't even a
minute and a half long and yet it still
manages to capture every detail that
makes the game series great spawn the
recall in 1997 spawn hit the big screen
and it was a disaster
the fan film spawn the recall succeeds
where spawn 97 failed in it a child and
his mother come face to face with spawn
himself who has a dire message that must
be delivered yes Berk fans nailed spawn
in eight minutes the best Hollywood
could do was this our Robocop remake was
an attempt to recreate or reimagine
every scene from the original 1987
Robocop movie dozens of Los Angeles area
comedians and sketch groups each picked
one scene to make as they pleased in the
end all of their stylistically different
work was stitched together to form one
utterly unique Robocop and it didn't
need Michael Keaton or samuel l.jackson
either dirty laundry
Marvel's 2004 Punisher movie was a
letdown star Thomas Jane more than made
up for it by reprising his role as the
vigilante in the short fan film called
dirty laundry all the Frank castles rage
and capacity for lethal violence is
unleashed when a normal laundry day is
interrupted by gang violence
it's brutal bloody and actually fun to
watch Batman dead end just when a
showdown between Batman and the Joker is
about to peak a new fighter enters the
match a xenomorph the acid drooling
monster from the alien movies the alien
pens Batman and then someone else shows
up and some others it doesn't make much
sense but it's awesome Severus Snape and
the Marauders set in 1978 this 25-minute
film tells the story of James Potter
Harry's dad Sirius Black Peter Pettigrew
and Remus Lupin as they bully young
Severus Snape after he tries to meet
Lily in a bar it perfectly captures
snakes in a rage and conflict as a man
who walks the line between good and evil
troops
if there were a fan film hall-of-fame
troops would be an immediate inductee
made in 1997 it's an episode of cops sat
in the Star Wars universe
starring dim-witted stormtroopers on
Tatooine it's groundbreaking for its use
of impressive low-budget CG effects even
better it's really funny Power Rangers
part fan film remake and part parody of
dark gritty reboots Power Rangers takes
the Kitty franchise and tell us how each
Ranger has spiraled downward in their
range of retirements it has a lot more
money behind it than most fan films and
more star power too with appearances
from james Van Der Beek and Battlestar
Galactica's Katee Sackhoff star wars
uncut Star Wars fan kcp you had a wild
idea a crowdsourced shot-for-shot remake
of a new hope fans claimed 15-second
segments of the film to remake and then
PU edited them together one moment harm
Luke and obi-wan are Legos and a second
later it's a bunch of kids in their
backyards with broom handles for
lightsabers a fresh take on a familiar
classic it adds up to one of the best
fan films ever thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which fan film you're a fan of